تفاصيل صادمه جديده في قضيه صاحبه قناه
انوش المتهمه بخفف الحياه على يوتيوب وبين
شاكيرا وبيكيه المعركه مستمره وامريكي
يعلن تقليص عمره خمس سنوات مقابل مليونير
حقيقه ولا خيال اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في مصر في يوتيوبر اسمها النبويه عندها
عدد من الحسابات وقنوات يوتيوب باسم روتين
انوش ويوميات انوش وبتظهر نبويه في
الفيديوهات وهي في المطبخ وهي بتمارس
حياتها اليوميه يعني عادي طبيعي يعني
والهنا احنا نقدر نقول لكم انه الموضوع
عادي ولكن في جدل كبير صاير حول
الفيديوهات
العامه تداول الفيديوهات هذه لاحد محاميين
حملت تطهير المجتمع الحملات واللي اطلقها
بعض ناشطيه ومحامي مصر للحفاظ على قيم
المجتمع انه يعمل بلاغ ضدها بتهمه ممارسه
الفسق والفجور على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي والاعتداء على القيم الاسريه
ومن بعدها اعلنت وزاره الداخليه الق القبض
على سيده بتهمتناشر فيديوهات عبر المواقع
الالكترونيه بتضمن ايماءات واشارات منافيه
للاداب العامه ومن بعد ما تم تحديد مكانها
تم القبض عليها ولقيو معها هاتف في
فيديوهات بتاكد نشاطها ولابتوبير وراوتر
وثلاثه كروز فيزا ومعدات تصوير واللاب توب
بعد هذا الخبر فورا الناس ربطت بيان
الداخليه باليوتيوبر النبويه او النصوص
وتصدر اسمها الاخبار والعناوين مع انه ما
تم ذكر اسمها ولا حتى نشر تفاصيل سوره
والشاعر من قبل الداخليه واما التفاصيل
الصادمه هياتي رافات انوش اللي قالت انه
من بعد ما ماتت بنتها وانفصلت عن زوجها
بدات تعمل محتوى على يوتيوب عن يومياتها
للكسب مال ويكون مصدر الرزق بالنسبه لها
والاولادها ولكن لما صار في مشاهده على او
ما صار في مشاهدات على المحتوى واستعاند
باحد الاشخاص وقت اللي بيعمل في احد قنوات
يوتيوب وهو اشار عليها انه تغير في
المحتوى وتلبس لبس فاضح عشان تجذب
المشاهدات وبالفعل هذا اللي صار وزادت
مشاهداتها وصلت لما يقارب 1000$ اسبوعيا
وقدرت تشتري شقتين ومن بعد ما عرفت طليقها
وشافها لبست الذهب واعرف انه صار معاها
فلوس طلب منها انهم يرجعوا لبعض ويرجعوا
وكان هو اللي بيصورها كمان ومن بعد هذه
الاعترافات تم الحجز على ممتلكاتها
ومجوهراتها وتم موضوع حراسه حراسه كمان
على شقتين بتمتلكهم في منطقه حلوان وقررت
الداخليه جديد حبسها اربع ايام
[موسيقى]
من بعد اسبوعين على الدراما الي صارت بين
شاكيرا وبيك بسبب اغنيتها لسرقتها مؤخرا
وهاجمت فيها بكى وجابت اكثر من 200 مليون
مشاهده ورد بيك عليها بتحويل الموضوع
لمكسب وشركات الي دخلت في الموضوع وغيرها
مستمره وما خلصت على موعد مع حركات وردات
فعل من الطرفين وهذه المره الرد جاء من
بيكي وعبر حساباته لاول مره
لحبيبته الجديده كلارا شيء على الانستغرام
وصوره يعني الحب والانسجام واضح فيها جدا
كانت بيكي لشاكيرا مع الفتاه هذه هو سبب
انفصالهم بعد علاقه اكثر من 10 سنين
وولدين ومن دون ما يكتب بي كي اي تعليق
على الصوره لكن الرساله وصلت يعني اول
اعتراف واضح وصريح بالعلاقه بين الاثنين
وفكركم مثلا شاكيرا سكتت من بعد بوستيه
قامت شاكيرا ونشرت بوست علقت فيه وكتبت
النساء
بيرقصوا ونشرت فيديو لها وهي بترقص
ماشي
[موسيقى]
يا عمري
اسمها صار على كل انسان في اسبانيا بسبب
الاغنيه كل هذا اللي شايفينه انه لسه هذا
هو الطريق لانه كمان في اخبار بتقول انه
شاكيرا بتجهز اغنيه جديده وهذه عاد راح
تنزل في يوم عيد ميلادها اللي هو نفسه يوم
عيد ميلاد اللي هو اثنين
ما زال الطالبان ماشيه في فرد قيود
وانتهاك حقوق المراه بشكل كامل فمن وقت ما
استلمت حكومه الحركه الحكم في افغانستان
والقرارات اللي بتخص انتهاك حقوق المراه
ما توقفت من التعليم بنتكلم عن العمل على
السفر واللبس وغيرها طبعا كثير فمن اشهر
اصدر الطالبان قرار بمنع التعليم الفتيات
في المدارس الثانويه وفي الجامعات واليوم
بتشدد وبتاكد على هذا القرار فمن المقرر
انه تبدا امتحانات القبول في الجامعات
الخاصه بافغانستان في فبراير وعلشان كده
منعت وزاره التعليم العالي التقدم الفتيات
لامتحان القبول والجامعات الخاصه وكذا
بتكون بتاكد وبتشدد عسكرارها اللي صدر في
ديسمبر 20 سنه 2020 واللي منعت خلال دخول
الفتيات الليل للجامعات حتى اشعار اخر
وعلى فكره كان كمان طلع وزير التعليم
العالي في وقت سابق وقال لو رموا عليهم
قنبله ذريه ما راح يتراجعوا عن قرار
[موسيقى]
وخلينا نبقى في اخبار حقوق المراه
والانتهاكات بحقه ولكن هذه المره من مكان
ثاني ونوع اخر امل دخل في التعليم ولا في
السفر
اعجب واعلن منع المراه من انها تدخل ورشه
تصليح سيارات من دون محرم ففي دكتور اسمها
انجيلا ابو اصبع رئيسه مؤسسه انجيلا
للتنميه والاستجابه الانسانيه صار معها
موقف غريب
سيارات علشان تفحص سيارتها وعلى الباب
منعوها دكتور الورشه لانه ما معها محرم
وابوها مسافر واخوها في شغله واصغر منها
اصلا ومعها هذا ما خلوها تدخل وتفحص
سيارتها من غير ما يكون معاها محرم ودجه
المنصات باسم الدكتوره واللي صار معها
ولكن من بعدها او من بعد ساعات تحديدا من
نشر الفوز حذفته من على صفحتها الشخصيه هو
على فكره القرار بمنع المراه من التحرك
بلا محرم كانت في العام الماضي وبررت ان
المراه شخص غير مؤهل للتحكم في حياته
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد في هذه الحياه يعني بنصادف
كثير من الاشخاص الفضوليين اللي يحبوا
يعرفوا كل شيء لكن الفضول اللي راح اتكلم
عنه في هذا الخبر يعني غريب منه شويه
يعني لانه وصل عند رجل برازيلي اسمه
لدرجه عاليه اوصل عنده هذا الفضول اللي
رجع عاليه كثير في الرجل قرر انه يعرف ايش
راح يصير لما يموت ومين راح يحضر جنازته
تحديدا هذا يعني عامل له ازمه الرجل عمره
60 سنه بيعمل في تنظيم وبيشرف على المئات
من المناسبات لاحياء ذكرها حياه الاخرين
ومن بعد التخطيط خمسه اشهر نفذ خطته اللي
حابب يعرف من خلالها مين راح يحضر جنازته
في كده الاول قال لنا شركوست على فيسبوك
طلب من الناس تصلي له وتدعي له وين ما كان
وكان متقسط في الصوره انه يبين المستشفى
خلفه والثاني يوم نشر بوست اعلن فيه عن
وفاته اعلان صدام عائلته واصدقائه واللي
صاروا بيتسالوا عن سبب تفاصيل الوفاء وايش
اللي صار مع من بعدها تم نشر تفاصيل
الوداع ومكان الجنازه وبالفعل جو اصدقائه
وعائلته كمان لمكان الجنازه والقداس في
كنيسه الصغيره بمسقط راسه وبس بدات مراسم
الجنازه طلع صوت وعبر مكبرات الصوت في
الكنيسه وكده كان المشهد
[موسيقى]
يعني مثل ما شفته بعد ما تجمعوا المعزين
من اصدقائه وعائلته في الكنيسه بدات
المراسم بصوت وعبر مكبرات الصوت اللي
موجوده في الكنيسه واصحاب وفكروا انه سجل
هذه الرساله قبل ما يتوفى وكان بيعرض صوره
مع اصحابه خلال الاعوام اللي عاشها والناس
بتبكي وقاتلين نفسهم من الزعل وفجاه طلع
قدامهم كده وكمل كلامه ولا لا وجلس 12
دقيقه كامله يحاضر فيهم وانه اللي عمل كده
وانه كان حابب يعرف مين راح يحضر جنازته
بعد ما يتوفى طبعا الذهول كان عنوان
الموقف اللي صار وتحولت مشاعر الحزن للغضب
والانتقاد بسبب اللي عملوه وحقيقه يعني
انا ماني من الناس اللي يعني يؤيده بس هذا
اعتقد الشخص لو كانوا ضربوه كان حلال في
بطن صراحه يعني
[موسيقى]
بعد يومين حندخل في شهر فبراير اللي هو
شهر عيد الحب اللي بيصادف يوم 14 فبراير
والاحباب بيحتاروا في هذا اليوم ايش
يجيبوا هدايا لبعدهم كيف تكون الهديه
مميزه وكذا وحركاته ومطاعم واشياء من هذا
النوع بس لكن في خبري الهديه ما راح تكون
للي احباب فعليين فلاح
للاحباب السابقين وتحديدا لان النهايات
يعني بينهم ما كانت سعيده ففي حديقه حيوان
في الولايات المتحده اعلنت انه مقابل خمسه
او عشره او 20 دولار يقدر اي شخص يروح على
الحديقه يسمى حشره باسم حبيبه
طعام لاحد الحيوانات في الحديقه لاحلى انه
الشخص اللي بتحط اسمه بيوصل له كمان بطاقه
الكترونيه من الحديقه بمناسبه عيد الحب
خفيفه لاحد الحيوانات اللي فيها
لاحلى واحلى انه مقابل عند 100 دولار يعني
الواحد لو بحبح شويه بيتم تصوير فيديو خاص
للحيوان وهو بياكل الحشره اللي عليها اسم
الحبيب السابق وارسالها له بصراحه فكره
متعوب عليها يعني انتقاميه كده ممتازه
يعني
الا ليت الشباب يعود يوما بعيد شعر قال
ابو العتاهيه من قرون وبيعكسها جزء من
وقتها ومن قبلها حتى لغايه اليوم عايشين
البشر كيف نفضل شباب كيف الواحد ما يعجز
اكثر بيقولوا هذه سنه الحياه وما في شيء
اسمه ايقاف الزمن لكن في رجل ثري كبير
الشركه في امريكا
علشان يوقف الزمان او حتى
عمره 45 سنه دفع كثير كثير السابق ومجهز
ملايين ثاني كمان اضافيه هذه السنه علشان
الفعل مجموعه من 30 دكتور يعمل له
اختبارات واجراءات طبيه برنامج اسمه
البرنامج عكس عمليات الشيخوخه في كل عضو
من اعضاء برايل وعلى فكره البرنامج متاح
للي يبغى مقابل 1,000$ الساعه حتى اليوم
نتائج البرنامج اللي بتقول
الولد قبل 45 سنه قلب عمره 37 سنه جل عمره
28 سنه همم شكله كده يعني مشدود مره جلد
رئتي عمرهم 18 سنه اما عمره البيولوجي
عموما فهو اصغر من عمره الفعلي ب 5 سنوات
البرنامج علشان يكون واضحين هو عباره عن
مجموعه فحوصات واجراءات طبيه مثل ما قلنا
لكن كمان في التزام من الزبون ببرنامج
واضح وقاسي من الاطباء فبراير بيتمرن ثلاث
مرات بالاسبوع لمده ساعه تمارين محدده
وقاسيه هو كمان ملتزم بنظام غذائي بياخذ
فيه في اليوم 1977 سعره حراريه مو 2,000
ولا 1,500 لا تحديدا 1977 سعره حراريه
والسعرات كلها طبعا بتكون نباتيه اما
بالنسبه للنوم فبينام في نفس الوقت كل
ليله وقبله به للساعتين كامله لابسه لابس
بيكون فيها نظارات بتحجب الضوء الازرق
طبعا كل هذا مخلي عنده الجسم اللي شايفينو
واللي فيه خمسه الى سته في المئه فقط دهون
الاخبار عن الموضوع طبعا قلبت الدنيا خاصه
لما الناس طلعت ضوء وطلعت صور مو من كثير
زمان يعني الي برايه يعني وصراحه في الفرق
واضح واصلا مجرد فكره الرجوع بالزمن هذه
الحاله كافيه تفتح الجدل ونقاشات لكن غير
هذا النقاش بين الناس بين العلماء في
انقسام كمان على الموضوع ففي وقت في علماء
ودكاتره شغالين على المشروع وبيطلعوا
بيانات في علماء ثانيين جالسين بيقولوا لا
ما في شيء زي كده والكلام هذا غير صحيح
وغير علمي عبر الهاتف ينضم الينا دكتور
اشرف الداد رئيس قسم الفيتولوجيا المناعيه
في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي اهلا فيك
معنا دكتور اشرف خليني اول شيء اسالك عن
هذه البروجكت هل فعلا اللي هو جالس بيسويه
يعني فعلا يرجع الشخص يرجع عمره لوراء
اسعد الله مساك بكل خير سيد الكريمه وعلى
المشاهدين هو حقيقه ما طلعنا عليها الان
من برنامج غذائي زائد يعني تمارين رياضيه
معينه حددت من اطباء متخصصين في مجال
اللياقه البدنيه
هو عباره عن
وليس غير طبيعي من ناحيه الجميع ما ياخذه
همم هذا الرجل الذي يريد ان يصغر سنه
يعتبر شيء طبيعي لاخ سواء من ناحيه الاكل
الذي ياخذه الغذائيه التي يقودها او
التمارين الرياضيه الصارمه التي يعني
يعملها يوم يلتزم بها يوميا ذلك
قبل ما ينام وكل هذا الكلام
هو معروف ان النوم الصحي يساعد خصوصا في
تحسين البشره
المواد المؤكسده التي تؤثر بطريقه سلبيه
على البشره واذا نام الشخص فان هذه مفعوله
سوف يكون اقل بكثير وكان هذه احد الشروط
طبعا ان يذهب دائما في نفس الوقت الى
النوم وايضا موضوع النظارات التي تحجب
الفلتره والضوء الازرق ايضا ان هي تحجب ال
ال ال العوامل البيئيه السلبيه التي تؤثر
على
الحياه الصحي هو اللي عامله كمان اضافي
موضوع انه عنده فريق الاطباء اللي جاسمين
طول الوقت بيفحصوا له همم
يعني عمر اعضاء والكلام هذا كله بس هل هذا
فعلا هيقدر يوقف التقدم في الثانيه يعني
هو بيولوجيا اقل من عمره خمسه سنين هل هذا
يعتبر انجاز
اي نعم يجب ان نوضح للجمهور انما يفعله
يعتبر رياضه زائد نظام غذائي صحي ولكن
صارم جدا الان اذا شخص عمره 45 سنه يوميا
يلتزم بنظام صحي او رياضي معين حتما سوف
ترجع رئيسيه عشر سنوات او ربما حتى 20 سنه
الى الخلف اذا كان عمره 50 سنه فهذا معروف
لدينا الاطباء اذا فحصل الرئتين مثلا بعد
الرياضه همم مده مثلا لمده سنه سوف تكون
همم تقريبا تشابه يعني سن اقل بخمسه عشر
سنوات وفي المقابل اذا لم تلعب همم تعمل
الرياضه او عملت على الدخان على سبيل
المثال الرئتين سوف تتقدم 20 سنه الى
الامام هذه الاشياء معروفه
هو ما يفعله فقط نظام صارم جدا يعني صعب
تنفيذه من الناس العاديين همم لكي يحصل
على اكثر مفعول فيه تصغير سنه وتنشيط همم
اعضاء والفلوس اللي بيدفعها دي كلها يعني
يعني احنا ممكن نعمل النظام الصحي بس انه
اروح ادفع مليونين في السنه هذه ليش
بيدفعها بس عشان متابعه الاطباء
البرنامج المشكله الاولى طبعا العامل
المادي الذي لا يستطيع اي شخص طبعا همم
توفيره او الحصول عليه والشغل الاخرى
النظام الصارم الذي حسب ما طلعنا عليه سبب
عنده اضطرابات نفسيه كبيره عند هذا الرجل
همم يعني صعب ان تذهبي الى كل يوم في نفس
الموعد
وتاكلي نوع معين فقط من الاغذيه همم ولا
يجب ان تلتزم بهذا النوع فهذا طبعا صعب
جدا هذه العاملين اعتقد همم صعبين جدا
ولهذا لا يطبق على العامه ما يفعله هذا لا
يطبق على همم ولكن في نفس الوقت يعني
موضوع التقدم في السن والامور هذه كلها في
دراسات صارت كثير جالسه بتصير على هذه
المواضيع وخصوصا في الفتره الاخيره كان في
تقدم في هذه اللحيه هل في خيارات او طرق
اخرى غير اللي هو بيعمله
نعم هذا سؤال مهم اعتقد ان العيش الايجابي
جدا في هذا الخبر انه يعني يعمل على الاقل
توعيه للناس لكي يعيش بطريقه صحيه يعمل
الرياضه ويوجد طرق اخرى طبعا اسهل من هذا
النظام الصارم ولكن في بدايتها وهي ما
يسميها بالانجليزي
تغيير ال ال الجينات التي تسبب اكسده
الجسم ويعني شيخوخه الجسم
وتحسين يعني البشره وتحسين عمل الاعضاء عن
طريق تغيير الجينات وهذا ما يعمل الان ما
يعمل عليه العلماء
يعني ولا ناخذ حبوب ولا ايه نعملها
عن طريق ادويه ادويه ياخذها الشخص وتغير
مثلا حمض اميني معين يكون مسؤول عن انتاج
اكسده زائده يعني والاكسده غير سلفيه
تعتبر من الجسم وخصوصا شيخوخه الجسم وشارك
كبير خصوصا ان هذا الموضوع الان يصرف عليه
وليس البلايين همم
10 سنوات القادمه سوف
نوع من الادويه التي تؤدي الى الاقل يعني
تحسين
الجسم واعضائه الفيزيولوجيه
يعني الاعمار بيد الله يعيش بصحه جيده
بنشاط جيد جدا ما يقدر نحنا بنشكرك على
هذه
المداخله والتوضيحات كان معنا عبر الهاتف
دكتور اشرف الدادر رئيس قسم البتولوجيا
المناعيه في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده